alors que le marché du vin français
recul certaines bouteilles se vante de
plus en plus celle de tambouille au son
des vagues sont mieux faire jean respect
vis-à-vis de la nature du bio dans les
vignes un rien de nouveau des
viticulteurs en produisait déjà dans les
années 70 mais ils étaient marginaux à
l'époque ils sont courageux ils font
quelque chose de nouveau c'est un retour
aux sources peut-être qu'il faudrait il
faudrait peut-être plus observé ce
qu'ils font et même essayer de
travailler avec eux dans une certaine
mesure pour savoir si nous ne pouvons
pas nous même baissé un peu
l'utilisation de certains produits ou
outre certaines méthodes c'est que la
production de vin et gourmande en
pesticides les premiers exposés au
produit
ce sont les agriculteurs eux mêmes ils
utilisent parfois trop mais souvent ils
ne sont pas informés sur la nocivité des
produits qu'ils utilisent et une plaine
par les précautions qui sont nécessaires
l'alternative biologique gagne du
terrain année après année le vignoble
français bio passe de 4000 234 ha en
1995 à 6304 en 2021 1403 en 2010 pour
atteindre 65 mille deux cent
quatre-vingt dix huit acteurs en 2018
c'est 11,96 % des exploitations de 20 la
filière a eu du mal à se structurer dans
les années 90 mais de plus en plus de
vignerons choisissent de se convertir à
la viticulture biologique parvenez des
solutions aura beaucoup de nos problèmes
actuels de société que ce soit en termes
de santé publique
ce soit un terme de revalorisation des
produits que ce soit en termes
d'environnement pour que le vin bio
soient certifiés ab il a fallu attendre
2012 avec un cahier des charges de ce
mi-temps paca la ligne l'ancien label
était uniquement lié à la production
c'était vin issu de raisins de
l'agriculture biologique mais c'était
pas la vinification et l'élevage des
vins qui était considéré ab sur les
bouteilles un repère clair pour le
consommateur qui a sans doute contribué
à l'explosion des ventes de vins pilloud
il s'en était vendu pour 413 millions
d'euros en 2012
plus d'un milliard d'euros en 2018 la
grande majorité des producteurs de vins
bio sont labellisés ab
mais certains autres ont penché pour
demeter ou biodyvin aux exigences encore
plus strictes que l'agriculture
biologique
[Musique]